well thank you David for that kind
introduction and it really is a pleasure
to be
our collaborations with
in fun and exciting and kind of seeing
where we can take these into futures is
really gratifying to see it this is in
presenting this specific talk this is
sort of the you know bringing coals to
Newcastle thing or perhaps in this case
I was thinking it's sort of bringing
pizza to new haven where you know this
is really where a lot of the you know
the initial and really most
sophisticated research on alcohol and
HIV has been conducted so we're really
early on in this process I want to
acknowledge collaborators at Brown and
also here and the funding support from
ni Triple A with a number of grants and
also from the brown see far has been
also helping us bring our alcohol and
HIV worlds together at Brown I also do
need to acknowledge the participants in
the Sun study and the Sun investigators
is i'll be presenting data from that
particular thing so you probably won't
have time to read all that so the
alcohol research center on HIV has a
number of research components I'll
quickly go over those before I kind of
dive into sort of some more recent data
one of our projects looks at alcohol and
hiv-associated brain dysfunction it's a
neuroimaging study longitudinal we have
a brief alcohol intervention for HIV
infected MSM and a primary care setting
which I'll talk about today we have a
similar type of intervention that's a
dual focus on on alcohol use and sexual
risk behaviors in the emergency
department that Peter Monte's the pif a
recent sexual minorities research
resource core that Donna / REO is the
p.i of and we're just starting to kind
of explore the connections with Yale and
I think those will be quite productive
and then also a mechanisms of behavior
change researched core resource core
that was funded this past fall the sort
of theme of all of those is that we're
really in a sort of our initial steps
here and David was kind enough to call
me a generalist or a master of none
perhaps but where we are we're sort of
new to this work but we bring a large
set of alcohol related research and
methods that we hope will be
useful as we as we go further so the
kind of key theme of our Center and this
is a slide that's existed since the site
visit a number of years ago is that
alcohol sits in the middle of a complex
nexus of biological and behavioral
factors that impact the depth and the
breadth of the HIV epidemic so we can
see that alcohol use affects sexual risk
behaviors which of course affects
transmission of the virus perhaps
increases susceptibility to acquiring
the virus through a variety of
mechanisms sort of not as well
understood alcohol certainly has effects
on medication adherence for people who
are infected perhaps interacts with
medications and their effectiveness
again that's not clear alcohol and
antiretroviral medications are impact
can impact the liver or certainly
processed there and then liver
dysfunction alcohol use and HIV itself
all can have an impact on the brain
which of course then goes back and
affects the behavioral aspects of
alcohol use medication adherence and
sexual risk behaviors so we're trying to
kind of elucidate a little bit of each
of those pathways to understand what are
the different mechanisms involved and
how do we make an impact in that so just
very briefly from from a meta-analysis
just to set the stage in case some of
you do not have sort of alcohol and HIV
as a central focus of what you do
alcohol consumption the risk of eight's
incident HIV infection is a significant
association more than double the odds of
binge drinkers getting an incident
infection versus non drinkers that's
from a meta-analysis a recent study in
MSM found that binge drinkers were sixty
percent more likely to have an instant
HIV infection compared to non drinkers
so certainly some strong associations
which means that the people who get
infected are more likely to be heavy
drinkers once infected the odds of
unprotected sex among people living with
HIV is also a significant association
where problematic drinking is associated
with the seventy percent increase in an
unprotected sex and then on the other
side of that of concern both for the
individual's health and of course for
transmission is that the odds of being
completely adherent to medication or
optimally adherent
duce with any drinking and reduce
without risk drinking and that's a very
strong consistent Association since been
seen in men and women intervene his drug
users numerous countries and this is
this is one of the most consistent
associations I would say that would see
Scott Braithwaite and colleagues here
looked at it's not just that binge
drinkers are different as people so that
they're always more not adhere and it
seems that the non-adherent really
non-adherence is most strongly
associated with the actual consumption
of alcohol so potential causal
association but even with that causal
association there's still what are the
reasons for that non-adherence it could
be forgetfulness or it could be
conscious decisions and SEF Kalesh Bin's
recent work suggests that people who
believe there was some interactive
toxicity between alcohol and
antiretroviral medications are less
likely to take medications on days they
drink and that about about a quarter of
drinkers in his samples report those
types of beliefs there's of course also
general disruption associated with
drinking problems d decreased healthcare
utilization and I think sort of
intriguingly that a study looking at
provider interaction with patients found
that heavy drinkers tended to have worse
interactions with their providers their
visits were shorter and there were less
engaging counseling statement so they
were a little more surface level on
visits so it could be that they don't
talk about adherence and some of the
problems with adherence as deeply as
they might wet with non hazardous
drinkers of course there's a strong
associations also with alcohol serious
illness and death non AIDS events among
hiv-infected adults who drink or higher
death is associated a higher death risk
for women drinking more than seven
drinks a week history of heavy versus
low alcohol consumption also associated
although a recent study found no
association between heavy drinking and
death when controlling for viral load in
karnovsky score which does suggest that
it may in fact be viral load and sort of
general medical health problems caused
by drinking that are contributing to
that death so this although the sort of
sounds like a negative study I think it
actually suggests that maybe that's one
of the mechanisms as opposed to other
causes of death such
as violence and accidents and so on that
could be associated with drinking there
been a lot of studies looking at alcohol
and HIV outcomes but I would say the
results are relatively variable but just
to give you a sense of that is our
reviewed some of those studies from the
early part of the decade five found a
positive association with greater
drinking and increased viral load for
found associations of decreased cd4
count and the three that didn't find
associations seem to have some possible
limitations in their sample or the
methods used Chandor's studies suggest
that the odds of being adherent down
there on the adherence is particularly
low so the odds of being adherence is
reduced with hazardous drinking by r
illogic suppression is also reduced
although you see that that association
is not quite as robust in almost crosses
one but within that study it was also
the case that it was not just drug use
it wasn't sort of that multi morbid
conditions that the association happened
whether or not there was drug use
present or not in the individuals so
pretty strong effect just a couple of
more recent studies the odds of
unsuppressed Bohemia and in a sample
with fairly high rates of unlock of
suppression a lot higher and a tryst
drinkers one recent study found no
association sorry I found an association
with drinking in viral load but only
among those on heart and not those not
on hearts so again whether or not people
are taking their medications I would
suggest it probably does go potentially
through adherence if there's that
association that one did not find an
effect on cd4 so I think in some cases
you see effects and other times you
don't again this just sort of
illustrates that the risk of having a
decline in cd4 counts again higher in
people with frequent alcohol use
compared to people who are moderate
drinkers and especially elevated people
use alcohol and crack but you see most
of the risk seems to come with alcohol
itself is where we see sort of a lot of
that hazard ratio being due to just
alcoholic use so you know those are sort
of the the key HIV outcomes that you see
the most on viral load and cd4 and of
course Amy justice and colleagues here
have developed a vaccine
as a way to measure some of the other
biomarkers that might be related to the
odds of patients surviving and it
incorporates information on age appetite
estatus viral load cd4 but also liver
function from the fib for kidney
function and hemoglobin as other
predictors and that one generally if you
follow this trend here does show if you
go up in the grayscale there a steeper
line associated with quintile of risk
from the vac score compared to an index
that doesn't have one so it being a a
more robust predictor of the odds of
death so what we don't know though is
really what about some of those
components and how do those relate to
alcohol use and can we tease that apart
so that'll be what I'll talk about now
some of those components and then
provide some data on that and then go
into talking a bit about interventions
as well so in terms of the liver liver
disease has surpassed aids defines
illness as the cause of death people
living with HIV it was president about
fifty percent of deaths from liver
disease in hiv-infected patients it's
certainly well known to be have had a
toxic and high doses and there are some
hypotheses about that HIV infection
infection may exacerbate these effects
and a lot of mechanisms have been
suggested increased gut permeability
increased inflammation fat accumulation
insulin resistance potentially an
interaction with HIV medications I don't
really think that the data are very
solid on whether or not they're sort of
like biologically plausible but I don't
think we really have a causal data
suggest whether or not that's actually
happening we do know that within HIV
patients that alcohol abuse and
dependence is associated with increased
fibrosis and cirrhosis as one would
expect it's also been shown to people
with co-infection greater AST to
platelet ratio index as a biomarker has
been associated with hazardous drinking
but there's still questions about
whether those have been the best markers
i'm used to date in a recent study
alcohol hazards alcohol use was only
found to be associated with higher AST
and alt and people who were co-infected
with HCV so again the moderators of
these
patients are not clear in mono infected
they did not find an association I think
that could also be a sample size issue
but it didn't seem to even be a trend so
a lot of the studies so far have
reported ast and alt fib 4 is an
alternative index of liver function on
that kind of harnesses measures both of
those measures and also platelets and
it's been found to be the best predictor
of cirrhosis and fibrosis and co
infected persons and it has been shown
to be elevated even in mono infection so
there may be some direct effect of HIV
itself on the liver or it could be the
medications the higher viral loads are
associated with fib 4 so at least we do
have some data on that it does predict a
pad of cellular carcinoma and HIV
patients the only study though that i
found that showed the direct association
over time between alcohol use and
infected and uninfected individuals
found no association between alcohol use
and 54 so that was a bit surprising it
was only in women and so again that sort
of suggested that we need to look a
little more deeply there about that
association so two of the other
components of the vax or hemoglobin and
egfr and those really have been in
general there's not a lot of work on
those done in alcohol use in general and
certainly not in hiv-infected patients
we haven't seen those parameters yet
published so in with hemoglobin alcohol
is actually associated with moderately
higher values so it potentially has a
positive effect although what the
meaning of it is biologically I'm not
sure we know it's been associated with
reductions in red cell count but
increases in being prosecutor volume so
it could be that there's something more
complex going on there than just sort of
a raw measure of hemoglobin we see
similar effects with smoking and
hypotheses that thats related to copd
and as people have more breathing
problems perhaps hemoglobin changes in
some way to compensate but I did not
find studies published in HIV patients
although I know that
the data are here at is one place for
kidney function rats fed a high
percentage of calories from alcohol do
end up showing reduced GFR and increased
catalase activity but in humans we
actually find sort of the opposite in
observational studies and evidence of
lower risk of reduced GFR with
consumption of seven plus drinks a week
and also that drinking frequency and
quantity are associated with a lower
risk of chronic kidney disease so it's
possible again alcohols has some
potential beneficial effects but we
really need to know within people
infected with HIV does it have any of
these beneficial effects and ultimately
what might be the meaning of those down
the road we think about the vax index is
one of the best predictors of survival
we really want to know those components
and it could be that people are going up
on one component and down in another
which we give a sort of a muddy picture
so that's one of the key questions here
how does alcohol relate to each of those
components and then within those you see
a lot of studies tend to make a rough
cut either they're using the audit or a
measure of alcohol abuse or dependence
but we don't really know what drinking
parameters are the most important is it
how often you drink is it how many
drinks total you're putting through your
body and your system is it heavy
drinking itself that's important so what
kind of classifications are the most
relevant and the interest of time I will
kind of short cut that discussion and
tell you that you know going in we
thought that frequency of heavy drinking
would be probably the most important in
that and hazardous drinking kind of
correlates with that so heavily that
they're often very difficult to separate
but we thought those would generally be
the strongest and that's generally what
we find in all these data we did look at
drinks per week and drinking frequency
and we just don't see the association's
as robustly so heavy drinking seems to
be sort of the best marker in that and
then we don't know within that sort of
importantly mechanistically if we see an
association between alcohol use and
worse HIV outcomes is that pathway going
through medication adherence or are
there other pathways than alcohol
having direct effects and likewise too
does the effect of alcohol vary by heart
status so that people who are taking
antiretrovirals perhaps have worse liver
function if they're also drinking
heavily because they're putting a
combined stress on the liver or perhaps
being very logically suppress my protect
your liver in some way so I think
there's a lot of questions there as well
and we don't know about co-infection as
well I would certainly think that hcv
could enhance some of these associations
certainly we think of liver function
people with hepatitis of any sort we
would expect that there would be a
stronger association between drinking
and alcohol alcohol use and liver
function so the method was the son study
this is a called the study to understand
the natural history of HIV and AIDS in
the era of effective therapy this is a
CDC supported longitudinal cohort study
the N that we have sort of valid data
for at baseline and going forward is 689
individuals in this cohort were only
exposed to combination highly active
antiretroviral therapy so these were not
people who were on single therapies mono
therapies and have been switched later
so these are people only initiating sort
of the modern era of therapy they were
followed for seven years there's a
couple follow-up still being finished up
but I cut it at seven years they have
assessments every six months and those
include kind of the typical serum
assessments that you would get and then
the behavioral assessments as well in
total that gives us 6754 assessments a
mean of almost 10 visits out of a
maximum of 14 or sorry I've got a 15
because the baseline visit counts is
sort of a zero so that's sort of the
sample they they come from these sites
there were four clinics Minneapolis
Providence st. Louis in Denver these are
relatively generalist clinics so these
are not sort of a VA or any kind of
specific population so in that way you
get you do get a fairly good
representation of men and women
relatively although the skew is much
more towards men to describe the
demographics of the sample a little bit
it's it is only just under twenty five
percent female
MSM are the largest group in this that's
65-61 % there's generally you know for
for HIV sample this might be on a
somewhat higher educated level than I
think a lot of people might find only
twelve percent were below a high school
education reasonably diverse sample
almost thirty percent african-american
about ten percent Hispanic Latino twelve
point seven percent HCV co-infection so
it's certainly there but not sort of the
dominant mode of trans to be co-infected
and then alcohol use at baseline so
there were thirty one percent point six
percent were non drinkers at baseline
now of course people transition out of
these categories over time and I use
sort of alcohol use of time-varying Cove
area than this but just to give you a
sense it's easier to look at it at one
time point 39.2 percent I drinking
without heavy drinking so there's really
quite a large group in that in these
analyses we did initially sort of do
these splits but we did find that the
the drinkers in that middle group who
were drinking without heavy drinking we
didn't see a lot of differences on
really any measure that we were looking
at so for this analysis I'll collapse
what I'll be doing actually it's a
contrast code where I compare heavy
drinkers versus these two groups and
then compare within those two within
these groups does frequent heavy
drinking make a difference relative to
infrequent heavy drinking so if you can
see sort of a dose-response Association
gives you a little stronger ability to
draw some inferences about what alcohol
use itself might be doing so this is the
analysis plan we used a
repeated-measures analysis using
generalized estimating equations HCV and
demographics were were measuring at
baseline alcohol use is a time-varying
cove area within that so at each time
point where we analyze that we put in
the alcohol use value at that particular
time point and then we're predicting the
particular biomarker at that given time
point adherence then was also used as a
time varying covariant so from that same
time point we then test interaction
between hepatitis C and time-varying
alcohol use and the interaction between
time varying medication status
and alcohol use that individuals may go
on and off of medication during this
trial as well not trial during this
observation so to start with adherence
this is sort of where we expected to see
the strongest signal across visits
eighteen percent of valid patient
observations include at least one missed
dose in the past three days now this of
course is a pretty rough measure in a
lot of ways one that it just only has
three days and of course it's only
self-report so that that's important to
note so we we kind of see this as people
who are probably pretty non-adherent in
general if they're willing to report
that they didn't take in the last three
days my guess is there something going
on these showed pretty strong
associations of heavy drinking so the
odds ratio for heavy versus non heavy
drinking if we just kind of make that
kind of broad cut seventy percent
increased risk of non-adherence so
that's actually pretty consistent with
the meta-analysis data so we see it sort
of in the same sample if we look at
frequent heavy versus infrequent heavy
we get a fifty percent increase so it
does matter how often you're drinking
heavily so I think that's important too
it's not necessarily just the people
this is controlling for a number of
potential confounds it looks like
frequent heavy drinking is worse than
infrequent so that one is pretty
straight forward all the others had some
sort of complexity in it and talking to
Amy and David today I think that seems
to be sort of the law of the land that
adherence we see really pretty
straightforward associations when we
then have to think that a pathway goes
through adherence to some other outcomes
so many other clinical and psychosocial
factors can be interfering in that
association so we looked at the log
viral load we had about just under
thirty percent of valid patient viral
loads or in the detectable range there
was a weak non-significant associated
with association with heavy drinking and
so it's sort of almost a trend it's not
a particularly robust effect and
importantly frequent heavy versus
infrequent heavy drinking actually
would've gone in the wrong direction we
expect this to be a positive association
so really in viral load we see a lot of
complexity and that could be a lot of
you know we don't have sort of reverse
causation we need
think about some of those things people
to get more sick maybe drinking less and
that maybe the times which your viral
load is high sort of a lot of different
factors going on but for all those
reasons we see sort of a relatively
muddy picture and again that's
consistent than about half of studies
that look at this find association a nap
dome it was not significantly moderated
by HIV status med status so we take
people only on antiretrovirals we did
not find any difference there either cd4
count was different though across visit
cd4 cell counts were reasonably high in
a good range there was a trend towards a
negative association with heavy drinking
in there so some heavy drinking compared
to no heavy drinking we had a P of point
05 when we had frequent heavy versus
infrequent heavy however again we had a
negative coefficient there again we
would expect a positive coefficient so
oh sorry sorry that one's sorry missing
that that's actually the right direction
but you know it's important to look at
the confidence interval there so we
expected a dose effect the sign is in
the right direction by there really
didn't look to be much of a dose effect
but there was a significant interaction
with HIV med so this is in contrast to
one of the studies are reviewed it which
is why I went through that kind of
comprehensive list that we found a
significant interaction on cd4 count
specifically so among those on HIV
medications we see a reasonably robust
Association of reduction of an average
of twenty points on the cd4 again though
we do not see strong evidence for sort
of a dose-response association there so
something about heavy drinking was
associated with with them reducing for
it was robust to control for medication
adherence in a cross-sectional analysis
and i'll talk about causal modeling in a
minute and there the the the picture is
a little more complex so fit for oh it's
actually fit for is in some ways more
straightforward than any of them and it
should be we expect with a direct
alcohol effect on him for we had about
twenty percent of values that were in
sort of a you know concerning range over
the cutoff of 1.45 it was positively
associated with heavy drinking and the
odds went up with heavy drinking so
that's a positive odds ratio with heavy
drinking and then free
when heavy drinking also has a positive
odds ratio relative to infrequent heavy
drinking so it was associated sorry
these are not odds ratios I've done it
both ways these are actually just
coefficients but in odds ratios you get
the same results that being above that
clinical cutoff is more likely with
heavy drinking there was no interaction
however with hcv with gender or with
antiretroviral medications so we see
sort of sort of non complicated effect
here which we're a bit surprised by you
know we do have to take into account
this sample did not have a high rate of
HCV so you know perhaps that could be
explaining part of that but it was
positively associated with log viral
load and also negatively associated cd4
even when both of those were in the
model together so we do sort of see a
general HIV related health correlating
with the FIB for as well and then
alcohol being another layer on top of
that so when you try to think of like
total effect there's a lot to consider
that alcohol use is definitely changing
adherence adherence may or may not be
relating to viral load alcohol seems to
be reducing CD for its worsening fib for
if people are doing worse and their HIV
outcomes they're doing worse than their
livery outcomes so I would say that
alcohols total effect when you think
about the total pictures is maybe a
little bit higher than it does when you
look at each piece for for renal
function only four percent were had sort
of abnormal values on GFR it wasn't
significantly associated that was not a
big surprise based on the result that we
had seen so we didn't see that but
hemoglobin was a bit surprising so the
average hemoglobin is 14.5 thirty-three
percent were below the level of 14 and
six point eight percent below at 12 and
it was significantly and positively
associated with heavy drinking so this
was going in the opposite direction we
sort of fought from previous data that
that's possible but was a was a little
surprised that sort of the robustness of
that association that the site the
magnitude of that was relatively large
compared to some of the association's we
saw it didn't seem to be a dosis effect
so more frequent heavy drinking didn't
seem to raise hemoglobin further but
engaging in some heavy drinking did now
people who drink heavily at least one or
two times a month they also are drinking
other days of
month as well so you know this could
also be something we divided up as
people who drink you know a fair amount
versus people who barely drink for some
people who don't drink at all alcohol
seems to have some effect on hemoglobin
it's not due to smoking status so we did
control for that there's no indication
that was that it was independent of
medication adherence so when we look at
sort of our total vac score given where
this sample is hemoglobin was more
likely than than most of other things to
be abnormal so if anything vac scores
would trend towards being better in
drinkers because of hemoglobin so we
were sort of finding in this or this
complex association where hemoglobins
doing something whether it associates
with positive clinical outcome we don't
know and I think that's really the
question that we need to answer is does
the reference range need to be just
changed for alcohol drinkers and that
was a question actually in a specific
article actually asking for general
population but I think that's something
we can look at it as we look at the vax
data perhaps we can go a little further
up that so lastly we're trying to get at
some causal inference in these data you
know it's difficult when you've got
these wave data so I've essentially just
shown a repeated Association over time
and all that does is kind of increase
power but doesn't necessarily tell us a
lot of about causality we have a lot of
potential confounds depression substance
use all of those things and the concern
is not that they affect alcohol per se
but that they also affect the
association between alcohol and HIV
status and that they can have a direct
effect on it HIV status as well so the
inference can be strengthened if you try
to do some sorts of causal modeling and
alcohol and adherence in image again you
can think of them as being presumed to
occur before the biomarker assessment
now that's that's stretching the
Assumption event right so you're you're
measuring the biomarker on that day
you're asking about the drinking from
the 30 days before but the biomarker
obviously reflects stuff that's been
happening during that time but I think
we can say that there's not a confound
and that we don't think that the
biomarker measured that day is what
caused your behavior over the last 30
days so I think at least there's enough
temporal you know Association to think
that that's the way it has to go
likewise I think we can say that alcohol
is more likely to cause non-adherence
than the converse that people are you
know they forget to take their
medications so they say
I should drink it's probably less likely
well you know I think what we're seeing
is much more of the opposite I plan to
drink so I'm changing so there's some
recent methods to handle these types of
confounds with lag data on valerian
vandenabeele have a really good paper
and psych methods that goes into this
and actually provides a algorithms for
SAS and spss to do it so highly
recommend that essentially what you have
is a model like this and I'll walk over
here a little bit just to point a little
more easily the key is that so this is
the outcome that we're interested in
that time T whatever that biomarker is
and then we want to control for what
happened at t1 we also want to control
for heavy drinking at t1 and then
essentially all these other things are
our potential confounds so whether
they're on medication or not and then
whether or not their adherence you have
to kind of create a way to deal with
that missing data and then from that
that has sort of the the beta path that
would be affecting our clinical outcome
we have drinking having its direct
effect and then we also have substance
use as a confounder depression and
employment as potential confound errs
you know kind of psychosocial changes
associated drinking as well and then we
can take all of these and we can lag
them back one so that we have a we have
drinking at a current assessment and
adherence at a current assessment we can
take a t minus one of all of those and
control for that and essentially what
you're then modeling is does change in
drinking in a given follow-up assessment
tell you anything about where they were
from their previous assessment and their
previous level of drinking in their
previous level of depression employment
etc so it gives you sort of that more
clean measure of change and it also
allows you to decompose effect into a
natural direct effect and a natural
indirect effect and those are sort of
like the sort of Baron in Kenny's
indirect and direct effects but it has
there's some other stuff you can do in
the counterfactual model of mediation
that lets you say a little bit
about that I won't for people with too
much of those details but this is fairly
preliminary right now so I don't want to
present numbers as if they are the the
final be-all end-all but what we see is
natural indirect or mediated effects of
heavy alcohol use on viral load and to a
lesser extent cd4 through its impact on
antiretroviral adherence so what that's
saying is people change their drinking
over time their viral their their
adherence changes at the same time point
and we do see this signal that that
seems to lead to changes in viral load
so you can have a non-significant direct
effect but you can show that the pathway
does in fact go through adherence we see
no significant natural direct effect and
again this is important to note that
this is change right so this is how much
you're changing or drinking we're
controlling for where they were drinking
before and what their outcome was before
their outcome before could be caused by
a whole lifetime of heavy drinking right
you're fit for value is caused by ten
years of heavy drinking we start
measuring you at the end of those ten
years this is whether or not your change
so this is important for patients to
know and this is important for us to
know clinically if we get change yes we
expect that that could impact medication
adherence and that can affect both of
these outcomes we also found a natural
direct effect of heavy alcohol use unfit
for and no significant natural indirect
effect and that's interesting to you
know a lot of clinical trials show that
changing heavy drinking does change ast
and alt we're able to show that in sort
of a very long-term observational type
of study with a lot of observations and
that seems to be a reasonably robust
effect and that's not through adherence
so it suggests that you know if we're
thinking to the total picture all three
of these are good predictors of survival
that alcohol is having an effect on all
of those but it may be he's happening
they're different pathways so hopefully
we'll have those results finalised over
the next few months so this gives us
sort of a you know this just sort of one
more piece of information like stacking
it all on there so we know that yeah
alcohols doing something and we're
learning a little bit more about how and
why and where and of course we need to
do something with it right so we need to
have some kites of interventions and
interventions hopefully the harness some
of this information to enable clinicians
to be better in what they do and also
patients to have been from
that they need so there's been a number
of clinical trials to try to reduce
hazardous drinking and people living
with HIV they most of them have not
targeted specifically people who are
heavy drinkers and had a specific
intervention just on on alcohol use so
it's actually a relatively short list
when you when you kind of take out that
the parson study was really I think the
first that was specifically focused on
heavy drinking that was an eighth
session mi plus cbt versus the same
thing but done in time and content
equivalent kind of control they found
effects on all the biomarkers that would
like to see and the behavioral markers
but not on alcohol use so that was a
little surprising but it's important to
know that's sort of both groups are
getting the same information and we
assume that information causes a lot of
change and they did show a big change in
alcohol use so that's really just about
the means of delivery I think it's sort
of imperfect the last quest studies a
little more clear they had individual
sessions plus an education referral only
which was really short and this was
again fairly intensive now they showed a
thirty percent reduction heavy drinking
an effective sex risk as well for people
who did combine in alcohol and sex but
they didn't report biomedical outcome so
we don't really know are these effects
going to filter down if that sort of
shows pretty decent effects that you
know we're starting to go away by 12
months but at least remaining someone
Becky papas and working with colleagues
here has done a trial in Kenya to do cbt
versus usual care and hazardous drinkers
with HIV and that one really is the
first to show effects on everything and
that in some ways really should there in
a there in a resource-poor setting there
giving an intensive intervention to one
cell and really nothing to the other
cell for alcohol so that's sort of the
ideal way to find out is it likely to
fall down and in fact yeah they found
the effects trickle down to adherence to
viral load to cd4 to everything I'm in
that study so I think that's kind of an
exciting finding this just sort of shows
the drinking effects and you can see
that you know over time the Additional
Sessions really do bring down
and it stays down in an experimental
condition but you know getting assessed
makes you drink less to as we know but
at least in this time it came through
nonetheless Debbie Hassan has a study
now impressed an addiction and no people
know that it's an addiction yet but that
was HIV infected population as well they
had sort of an advice condition an mi
condition and mi plus a health call and
there's they've already published the
pilot study on that which is just
interactive voice recording what did you
drink sort of every day it gets people
kind of continuing to focus on it and
they can get feedback on their drinking
at the end of a month what it went it
looked like so they're they're mi is
sort of enriched with the with the data
that the people actually report they
found if you had non-dependent drinkers
that all arms are doing a pretty good
job of reducing drinking no differences
there fifty percent reduction though and
but that mi plus health call was
particularly useful independent patients
so there does seem to be some sort of
severity matching so we're kind of
getting there i think we're learning a
little bit about the studies and you
know maybe what might be important but
possibly maybe a more middle middle
intervention is going to work so with
all that context where we are in the in
the process of running a study now
that's looking for sip specifically at a
brief intervention for HIV infected MSM
at HIV primary care setting the study is
is taking our work that we've already
done in mi in the emergency department
and also with smokers combining it with
more good idea with John Morgan's turn
on a gold choice intervention for
alcohol use disorders and MSM who were
not HIV infected and in that study what
we found actually is if we had an mi
condition versus cbt plus mi and what
this told us here is that mi actually
made a quicker reduction in drinking
compared to cbt plus mi and then they
sort of flattened out it sort of that
was consistent across a lot of variables
we looked at our feeling actually in
that was that mi has a certain advantage
in being short and not saying we need to
teach you anything just being that
you're ready to change and you can do it
and here's the information so that kind
of encouraged us that may be going
fairly brief would be good and allowing
people to have their own goals about is
it
substance or reduction as well as
feasible we've since done another trial
I think we're doing analysis right now I
think there's only eight that we found
true RCTs in MSM for hazardous drinking
so this was only the two of those eight
here so there's not a lot to go on when
you think about specifically tailoring
interventions around this and we in this
case had naltrexone and then a fairly
involved MI and cbt ish coping skills
type of intervention versus people and
the other condition got a really minimal
sort of how you're doing on your
medications and that's about it really
very very minimal counseling what we
found was that if you got naltrexone and
that minimal thing that's this top one
that that you're you're drinking reduced
but not that much okay and then if you
got now treks on plus counseling or the
counseling that's the triangle there you
did pretty well maybe now Trek sonax a
little faster than sort of skills
training and that makes sense that you
would expect naltrexone should start
doing its thing pretty quickly but that
it really didn't matter how trek zone
wasn't adding much necessarily so again
an indication that perhaps for a lot of
people who are heavy drinkers but not
heavily dependent not being seen
addiction settings that perhaps
treatment without medication may be
substantial enough and I think sort of
the trial going on here will be sort of
another way to to kind of tease that
apart so our study and I'll just give
you the very very quick version of this
we're recruiting 220 for HIV infected
MSM from fenway health they're all
hazardous drinkers they can be dependent
they can sort of carry virtually any
comorbidity with them that they would
like except current IV drug use and they
can be depressed and sort of everything
else we're really trying to make it as
much as we can in like the clinic they
get treatment as usual which is
treatment as usual plus assessment which
is an intervention or a brief
intervention then we have follow-ups at
three six and twelve very briefly the
drinking about 30 drinks a week so this
is quite a heavy drinking group
thirty-four percent of the days they
drink heavily depressive symptoms are
very high all above the cutoff and
that's sort of typical HIV
populations high-risk sex not that there
weren't screen for iris sex so it's not
necessarily highs this is a secondary
outcome and study do we reduce high-risk
sex antiretroviral adherence only about
nineteen percent or not you know sort of
poorly adhering detectable viral loads
you know even lower than that so again
the idea that not everyone has to be
adherent to get their cd4 counts only
about twenty percent below 400 abnormal
liver function however we see a lot more
so this is sort of consistent what we
see that you know our sense so far the
Sun data on this date of that that
people can be in care and doing pretty
well and drinking heavily and even being
not adhere in a fair amount it won't
necessarily show up in viral load or
maybe even in cd4 but you know liver
function maybe one place where you're
going to find HCV is very low in this
group so this liver function dysfunction
is from most likely from drinking
potentially from HIV as well but given
that how well the viral loads control my
guess is that a lot of that would be a
drink so we've done treatment
development we had sort of five
participants we went through a process
of identifying the challenges and so on
the the challenges where not only the
severity of the psychosocial problems
that was a big part people a lot of
mental health problems psychosocial and
stability residential instability
financial problems length of assessment
intervention I'm sure we've all lived
through the Hat trying to make it
shorter but we're not getting there and
we needed to be sustainable we felt like
one visit was just not enough in this
case even though we were thinking one
visit with some phone calls and so now
we've sort of increased that a little
bit i'll tell you about that and then we
have the complexity of the feedback i'm
sure i'm not going to get to everything
i won't go through mi anyone raise your
hand if you don't know am i okay so it's
mi they do all that this is the other
piece I wanted to mention just as we're
thinking about like data across studies
is we're do the timeline follow back and
then we have to assess their drinking
their drug use their sexual behavior and
their medication adherence sort of on
every day for 30 days and this is sort
of what it looks like this is one day's
worth of data so we're this went through
a lot of iterations but essentially
we're going to be collecting and how
many doses were you supposed to take how
many didn't
did you take actually if there was a
difference what were the reasons for
nonadherence so that was something we
added based on Calvin's work and I'll
show you a little bit of data on that
and then we also go through every single
partner you know anonymous casual first
time dating long-term male female male
to female etc all the different sex acts
that could have occurred where they
protected etc and there's still like 10
more questions we would like to ask but
it just goes on and on so I think these
kind of data are really rich and really
valuable like they take a lot of patient
time and I assume a lot of code in time
but this was interesting we found that
you know we have a lot of days to report
on from the first 75 people forty-one
percent are having some missed dose in
that 30 days so it's actually pretty
good adherence overall in the sample we
have 148 missed dose days and 95 of
those were drinking days so definitely
drinking is coinciding with the missed
dose although these people are drinking
pretty high like 50-something percent of
days so there's just a base rate
phenomenon there but this was
interesting so we did look at the
adherence reasons for non adherence and
this cuts off but this is where you're
drinking or not drinking on a given day
they listed a few more reasons on the
day this actually is higher than 148
because people listed multiple reasons
when they were drinking couldn't decide
was it basically was it routine
disruption on the drinking day or was it
unintentional lack of adherence but this
is the big thing here this is substance
you so this could be other drugs to it
right we didn't we didn't feel like
people could answer unless you made more
broad but a lot of the non adherence on
drinking days that substance related
that the patient Lee says the substance
related they're saying are intentional
and there really are saying not that
like while I was drinking I decided but
I knew going in that I was not taking my
meds that day it was a party day so I
think for intervention development
that's actually changing how we do our
intervention instead of talking a lot
about well when you drink you know you
can't control your intentions as well
and there may be all this impulsivity
and stuff in fact we're really feeling
that we actually have to go more at this
and talk about sort of that intentional
decision the other things are you know
relatively more you know more
even across those sometimes
psychological factors a little bit
higher on those days but not given the
number of days we had we had more so
that's not really an association so not
sort of statistical significance here
but clearly clinically we know we have
to do our work in a way so lastly just
to show you like what we do with an
intervention it's it's a lot like a lot
of brief interventions would be we have
feedback we do take this from the Mac
study we do so this is norm for MSM in
urban settings so we give them a norm
about their drinking level and where it
fits in and we find that for a lot of
people this is very impactful you don't
have to do it we're getting a lot of
resistance we don't go here because
people then just get really upset but if
they're sort of open and engaged then we
kind of say where do you fit in here and
you know all of our participants are
fitting it in here and they also get a
percentile and this was sort of the the
feedback innovation is we couldn't go on
and on for pages long as people of
cognitive impairments and so on so we
had to do it in one really one page of
feedback and what this does is based on
our interview with them and their
medical record we type in a bunch of
numbers and then these arrows light up
depending on the data that we put in and
we print that out for this individual
patient so a red arrow for medication
adherence immune it's less than ninety
percent it would be yellow if it was
less than ninety five percent sex risk
they're engaging in some some risky sex
but not necessarily high transmission
risk brain dysfunction in this case this
person has one subtest of the
neurocognitive assessment that they had
a deficit in if they have to then that
goes to red liver health again that's
pretty obvious substance use sort of
again we light that up for depending on
how many of you whether it's multiple
substances how often happens smoking we
sort of would always like that up is red
and in viral control people are usually
pretty good but again that can go
depending on sort of your level viral
control and actually immune function CD
for you it's in there too and then we
have this sort of back page and what
this does is we take our that timeline
data that we've talked about and we try
to use it in the clinical intervention
so right up here for this person it was
days not adhere in the past three months
so that was based on a casa so we also
have sort of a broader measure that's
how
more impersonal we talked about that and
then from the timeline follow back we
say you missed four days in the last 30
and on those on the days you drank you
missed three times and on the days you
didn't drink yelling this once you know
what do you think about that why is that
Association there and then we have the
same thing for unprotected sex too and
this really leads to a rich discussion
where people can say hey I don't like
taking my pills on the same day I think
it's a problem or when I drink I'm
always had a friend's house and I'm ever
around my pills all sorts of different
things sexual health we get very complex
responses where people are saying I'm
making real decisions about what's high
risk and what's not who I can be with
and who I use a condom with and who I
don't and so sometimes it sounds very
intentional alcohol is just sort of part
of it but they didn't violate any of
their intentions other people really are
saying that they really feel like
they're losing control when they drink
and so that's really really helpful and
important to get that sense in this data
helps us do that so lastly I'll just
spend a minute on this we have time for
questions you know because these
interventions are new and we won't have
outcome data for a while we're going to
start you know kind of slotting slugging
through them and figuring out you know
what is it in the intervention that
works what doesn't work what counselor
techniques are affected in getting
people to consider change and commit to
change and so that's what this is
related to we've got co-investigators
here and Hopkins and UAB and essentially
what we're trying to do is is
state-of-the-art mechanisms research on
these alcohol HIV interventions to break
down what happens in the session and
I'll tell you that quickly and then to
be as a national resource that we can
help other studies that are doing this
kind of work do this so we have these
participating trials two of those you
recognize from here to I've mentioned
and then the one that's a scenics trial
going on at UAB what we have is that
everyone's different we've got different
providers social workers medical
providers paraprofessionals sometimes
they're using mi explicitly sometimes
they're not sometimes alcohol is the
target other times it's more secondary
sex risk is disgusts it's the primary
outcome in this study adherence is
discussed in some studies it's the
primary outcome in one study sometimes
there's alcohol far because
therapy sometimes is not so we have all
sorts of different topics and contents
in them so we're trying to take the
motivational interviewing skills code
and map that on so we can figure out
what happens are they using mi types of
techniques and if they're not is that a
problem and then we have to code sort of
every single utterance and what were
what was the topic what was it about and
how did they talk about the topic so
determine if councillors whoever they
are maybe worse at certain kinds of
discussions with certain kinds of
patients under certain kinds of
conditions and qualifying what's worse
and what's not is the trick but you know
we'll skip through that but we're trying
to figure out you know just provider
language perfect predict behavior client
behaviors that down the road but
essentially everything for just if
they're talking about alcohol you have
to know what they're talking about the
patterns the consequences barriers to
change facilitators their goals
treatments they've tried what they're
doing in the meanwhile to kind of make a
change and a bigger thing what are they
doing that kind of getting in the way of
making a change so you have to kind of
code every single utterances is it
something of that and then within that
you have to decide what's the speech act
and this is a partial list it goes on
and on it only gave you one little piece
but is that an are they just asking for
information or the giving advice are
they confronting are they expressing an
emotion expressing empathy making
hypotheses etc so eventually we will
have gazillions of data points and
hopefully enough time to sort it all out
and so we got to transcribe about a
thousand tapes and we're just starting
to kind of apply these now and then
we'll be able to use those causal
modeling methods to look at what are
those sort of interactions mediational e
as well and so that's hopefully
something you know in a few years maybe
I'll be able to come back and tell you
we've got on that and so on that I'll
say thanks